yeah welcome to this video a 15 minute
game let's play default phone this from
Canada at least that is the Canadian
flag 2080 so pretty good rating here for
the 15-minute pool they are not so many
players and the Queens gambit I could
also make it a Catalan with the g3 but
let's see what happens here likes got a
wide range now he's playing them the
classical line there should be seven
yeah here white mostly chooses between
Bishop g5 and Bishop f4 I always
preferred Bishop f4 for the Sun makes a
little bit more difficult for black but
ok this line I'd beat his heaven has
gained popularity in recent years and
the Sun real tough nut to crack in terms
of getting an advantage for white I play
the slime myself as black so I have some
ID mc5 phone or a 3 this is so these are
the main moves hmm ok let's let's try
see Wi-Fi I think this is a bit more
testing the question now is c6 all night
h5 night h5 has some the moves that
Kramnik plate also um I think Peter
heinen years and played that the Shaolin
sir form a second is now working with
Magnus Carlsen but high heels and
awesome long-term long-term second offer
honored the nith 5 ism as an alternative
I go h3 here to make sure that the
bishop can ratite can retreat to h2
and this is the idea black no goes age 5
a 3 & here blacks got yeah he can play
Bishop a 60 B should be seven preparing
all this bishop asics sometimes on gam
can be M answered with Bishop takes a
six rook a six and then be five this
leads to a very complicated game I'm not
sure that this really is some is so good
for for white that's um it's a
possibility so I'm talking about take on
a 606 B 5 takes on b5 c6 to get a nice
see porn but this can be answered by um
both Queen c8 and before I think not
sure what's better but it's not too
great for wide so i cannot really avoid
the trade here should i take or is that
something better yeah if I wouldn't him
if I would have played h3 then I could
maybe play Bishop or have the bishop on
these three and I could castle but it's
not the case here okay just take it rube
cakes and yam Castle cm
you
yeah probably just castles um yeah now
black himself named could take on before
and term go from them or Quincy eight
this is also a good idea Quincy a to be
seven and then look F to beard Wade yeah
in general this some light doesn't
really give right much but this is some
true for the whole line with the night
bd7 in general as mentioned i am have
played this myself a couple of times and
really it's not it's not the line that
inspires them it's very inspiring for
for white okay so but I'm not sure about
Queen aid so is it possible maybe to go
b5 now if he takes Knight be five
there's some nights e7 as a possible
idea I'm not sure that this is really am
much to write home about
I'm not really so how to make them any
kind of progress here cannot leave the
first rank because of 8x before I cannot
play queen bee three e2 or something
like that normal move got to move the
Queen along the first rank but then
where's my plate oh the only idea is
really related to to be five
so b5 takes 9 p-5 just Quincy six maybe
yeah 97 done we can at least play okay
seven simple chess maybe I can take on
v6 I'd have 10 PS Roxy one would be one
night see 7s there's some out something
else a ticket play probably not be five
hook 87 I've Queen a forwards this looks
like a little bit of something okay
let's try this on otherwise I probably
have nothing maybe this way hell so if
nothing but at least it looks like i'm
some idea yeah this whole line them with
night BTW 70 can be recommended if you
are are content with a solid but
somewhat dull admittedly position i have
played this as mentioned myself it's a
it's a good line to UM to UM to know
simply for games where you don't mind to
draw and where you yet didn't have the
opportunity to prepare something special
for example I play in the first league
in the Netherlands or in Belgium I quite
often get really good opponents with
black that it couldn't really prepare
against so um it's not such a great idea
to play some opening that you don't know
too well and this and maybe complicated
stuff and if it's not too bad to draw
the game then this kind of stuff with
blackest is really am
yeah worth considering you don't have
any a big problems in the opening and um
um can play with them come from a very
solid position to try to try to draw
even sometimes sometimes when I don't
have any bad experience with this the
opening results always have been have
been good okay so what now the Queen
detects the night obviously and also c5
the same idea was 97 and then grab on b6
trying to learn to do something with
them the temporary activity don't really
am see any M any become alternative so
let's go here if you play something like
a five I can I can just take with the
pawn I'll carry the rookies also hang so
this is just just nonsense anyway okay
so takes on b6 this was my attention
okay so and my idea was that on Queen
Queen takes I can play rook be one and
then not be five with tempo back and i
hope to UM to have a slight edge with
the with the somewhat more active pieces
maybe this is just an illusion as
possible so night b5 now or is there
something else I could hmm yeah well the
a porn is saying was thinking about
Queen to to see one ok let's drop this
back the neither some liability anyway
on c7 the some grabs this this temple so
um yeah this rupee seven or so the move
that dumb can be expected and what now
yeah should I play a for I don't know a
for would anchor the nitrogen hard to
learn how to judge on how the queenside
situation I mean a play for this might
be vulnerable to possible Knight b6 at
some point on a three-year however the
the pawn is also under check by the
bishop on a fade a for however allow
something like Bishop before which is
also not what I'd like to like to see so
maybe I should should delay this and
then just just capture and just a cover
me with a move like this Queen III he
cannot them play rugby eight anyway
because of the f4 Bishop and now I'm
intending night rook to see one okay
maybe maybe I think I've got I get a bit
of pressure on the queenside to the
night on b5 is slightly annoying okay
just occupies
to see file yeah of course this also
prevents them the Roxy one idea and
maybe a min 10 some night green to see
form
yeah it's not much it's really not much
Quincy forum this kind can be a an
annoying move I really don't see how to
get something on the C file I mean if
the Queen would be on some other square
I mean each or something then e for
books you won't even know it would be an
option but this in this way simply
nothing
okay yeah this is some more less than a
pass don't don't really see a way to
improve the position
don't mind this exchange really take
with the rock anthem now an f3 wasn't
doing so much anyway yeah maybe I should
play yeah a4a for always might be six
cents an annoying move that black can
simply take on the two I can maybe even
try a five-speed more vicious but
probably am that's a possible move so
Queen takes us p5 hey now or we also
need to take here
and one about 96 96 20 could be am
problematic yeah it's always a bit
tricky to play against the lines here
you play yourself then I will be be five
maybe didn't the network management or
made some some some less than accurate
move some later let's easily am easily
possible he wants to go nitey form again
okay so come on let's um finally and
make sure that this night is so I want
to save square dumb the night on them
yeah the night here is quite far away
from be 60 and unwind a chicken Roxxxy
one he cannot take a four because of
Rube CITS got a week back rank rook c8
Bishop to F 896 should be heir should be
good for white and he cannot play works
his seven if he needs to take now and
give me a give me the sea fowl and then
I better not not much maybe initially
but it is something that you can try to
to build up a bond improve even further
it cannot take I think rook c8 push-up
f8 96 and went is pinned on the throwing
and I think this this must be must be
good for for white probably winning
and if we play some some zero move then
it's interesting I can maybe take and
the sea porn could be a weakness with
Roxy one quickly the question is some
what about a forcing move like g5 which
also would them take care of the week
back rank maybe this is some this is a
good move yep found that okay let's say
I take and play f3 whom I hope um this
is right okay i move the bishop then i
probably can take a fall so let's grab
this first takes on c4 came and then i
have fun to 200 singles bishop c7
attacking the porn or also f3 f3 might
be a might be interesting i can maybe
just take b5 very very tricky the ship's
is 7s sighs so sku attend somehow i'm
i'm catching this rupiah doesn't have a
square but he's got the sea porn
this can can be very tricky move like
Bishop before and c3 so it's very quick
em mm-hmm maybe I should have considered
this a bit more carefully okay I'm down
to two minutes and something just isn't
too great okay I'm expecting a bishop
before not really otherwise I think I
can just take it on a five I mean uh huh
okay okay let's take it I can play book
see one now and then it cannot the pawn
cannot advance and I mean okay it can go
to see three but this doesn't matter so
much my king is is quick enough to to
help
hard to say maybe this is suraj equal he
needs to take care of the c-4 pond and
then my point simply m control the the
whole fifth-ranked so he cannot really
use the king tool to help but i also
don't see a way for me to improve it yes
d 5 is always got Bishop c5 okay let's
try this this is very ambitious with
little time on the clock but it's so not
exactly important I mean can experiment
a bit
try to get to the sea for porn after all
like this I mean maybe this is so too
risky and possible especially
considering the time situation Wow so
what about d6 yeah well I don't know I
mean I don't want to draw with them
maybe this I should have taken it i
don't know i don't have much time just
130 yeah my pawns on light squares so um
this is quite good against this bishop
so the position is maybe m-maybe are all
right the time is so is the real problem
yawa from a practical point of view I
should have should have taken the draw
as much as clear this position I
certainly cannot win so I'm probably
just much worse yeah yeah maybe just
lost you don't don't see how to defend
against the pawns
yeah yeah I'm not sure that you played
this ur the best possible way but tests
probably are still so winning
yeah not much I can do
you
yeah just g2 and and / or am i
overlooking some some brilliant idea
don't don't really think so yeah well
this wasn't so difficult right yeah no
one can resign yeah I probably should
take the draw with them with a little
time I mean I actually believe that that
I should be yeah maybe I'm not better I
thought I have some chances to learn to
use the better pawn structure but it's
it's really difficult with the time
maybe it's also that is bishop with some
it's better in the position may be some
somewhere around here and of course I
can just take it 6am this is also
probably the simplest the problem was i
I really didn't see that this is I will
check all the time 93 s also somewhat
better for more time and I want the
night only for you need to attack g5
yeah now it's got rookie 5 this is the
problem I don't really get them computer
give this as equal actually
no night 85-95 is a draw funny yeah well
with one minute on the clock interesting
still 95 is a draw yeah the computer
calculates this to a dead draw night on
h4 so the problem i did stops the upon
yeah okay you can can you calculate this
with some time on the clock not in this
situation yeah thanks for watching not
the most exciting game troll leave it I
went into this somewhat dull line yeah
thanks for watching